[Music]
Okay, today we're going to try
to figure out how wagon...
Today we're going to try to figure
out how dragonfly wings work
So Phil has a dragonfly that I
caught last night on our night walk,
and we have a high speed camera,
and we are set up the macro lens
to try to collect that exact spot.
So tell me when to trigger.
(Phil) Let's go.
(Destin) You got it?
(Destin) Holy cow.
- Looks cool, doesn't it?
- Oh man.
- Yeah?
- We got it.
- Awesome.
[Music]
(Destin) Alright, so you have one
of your entomology books here?
- You know it.
- Which book is it?
- Borro and DeLong's Intro
to the Study of Insects.
This is a classic entomology book.
So with these guys the
muscles are actually
pulling directly on the base of the wing.
So it's a direct flight mechanism. Um...
- So what's an indirect flight mechanism?
- Indirect flight mechanism, it actually
just pulls on the body wall of the thorax
and the collapse or expansion
causes the wings to then move.
- So we're going to go from the rainforest
to a rainy day in my home town.
Now, we have all different
kinds of art projects here
and the one I really want to show
you is the dragonfly project.
What they've done is they've
given metal dragonflies
to all the different
organizations in the town
and they let them paint
them however they want.
What I think is cool about the dragonfly
is that the wing attaches to the body in a
completely different way than most insects.
To explain this I've decided
to become a dragonfly muscle.
This is a wasp.
To see how normal insects operate their
wings we need to cut the thorax in half
so we can see the muscles
operating on the inside.
Eeugh, it's uglier than I thought. Anyway,
The wings of most flying
bugs use this method,
which is called indirect musculature.
The muscles pull on the body wall of the
thorax instead of on the wing itself.
The shell then pushes on the wing,
which seesaws on a pivot
point and moves up and down.
The problem is muscles
pull - they don't push.
So how does the wing return?
If you would've imagined that the
thorax was shaped like a football,
the big muscles would be squishing
the ball in on the middle.
When you turn it on its side you
can see that this little muscle
runs the length of the football and
pulls in longways from the inside.
This makes the middle bulge back
out, which moves the wing down.
Dragonflies, however, operate differently.
When we look inside a dragonfly
we can see that they have what's
called direct musculature.
Their muscles pull directly on the
wings and are able to operate
each wing independently in both directions.
This is a big deal,
and this is why completely
dominate the insect flying world.
If you look back at the high speed,
in those little cracks you can see muscles
wiggling and pulling directly on the wings.
That's pretty awesome, huh?
(Phil) So, they say "in many
Odonata," which are dragonflies,
"the front and hind wings
move independently,
and there is a phase difference in the
movements of the two pairs; that is,
when one pair is moving up, the
other pair is moving down.
Okay, Dr. Jim Usherwood in the UK
and his colleagues discovered that
because dragonflies have two sets of wings,
for the most part they're inefficient.
More inefficient than just normal
insect flight with two wings.
They made a robot with two pairs of wings
and they would vary the timing
between the two, and they found
that at a certain timing they
could get 20% more efficiency
than they could with just two wings.
Dragonfly wings have something
on them called the pterostigma,
which is latin for "wing mark".
You may have seen them before.
This is a dark cell
on the leading edge of the wing that's
heavier than the rest of the wing.
At a certain velocty, thin wings
begin to automatically vibrate,
which makes it impossible to glide quickly.
With the added weight at this
particular spot on the wing,
these vibrations don't start
till a much higher airspeed,
which means dragonflies
can now move much faster.
Turns out it's a complex
aerodynamic structure
built right into the design of
the wing to help them glide.
Every time I see a dragonfly I
always try to spot that spot.
Wait a second, have you ever
seen a dragonfly glide?
Okay, in this last video you
can see that we're in a canoe,
we have a Phantom Miro high speed
camera and we're trying to capture
these dragonflies as they
lift up off the grass.
Now, you cool thing about it is you can
see that he uses his wings to hover,
but he also uses them as a way of gliding.
It's incredible, 'cause can see
him feather the front wing
and allow it to glide the
air over the second wing.
I've never seen anything like this.
Check it out.
[Music]
So I hope you learned something along
with us about dragonfly flight.
If you've liked us, subscribe
to Smarter Every Day.
Please qui... click the flying dragonfly
here that my kids are propelling for you,
and, uh... you'll subscribe.
I'm Destin. You're getting smarter
every day. Have a good one.
(Destin) What happened to your tooth?
(Sadie) [Unintelligible]
- Don't tell them what I payed for it.
[Kids laughing]
(Destin) [Laughing] Stop. Stop.
Okay, in this last...
[Train nearing]
There's a train. It's loud everywhere here.
Okay, in this last video we've got the
Miro high speed camera in the canoe
and we're looking at a dragonfly,
and we get to see it lift
up off a piece of grass...
[Sniff]
Dripping snot.
Man. Waiting on dragonflies.
It's kind of boring.
[Kids laughing]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.